[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARC CRANDALL: Hi, folks.
My name is Marc
Crandall, and I handle
global regulatory compliance
with Google Cloud.
A little bit of background.
I'm a lawyer by training.
I'm part of Google
Cloud engineering
to help ensure that the
products we provide to customers
meet their regulatory
compliance needs as best we can.
We focus on three areas.
The first thing is working with
the sales organization as well
as our legal teams to find
out what the latest trends are
from a compliance perspective
and what the market needs.
We work with engineering
and product management
to drive change within
the organization
to help address those needs.
And finally, we work with
regulatory authorities
to help learn what the
trends are from regulators
and also get their input when it
comes to building our services.
I've been at Google 12
years and as a lawyer,
helped launch one of Google
Cloud's first product
offerings, G Suite, in 2006.
So let's move forward.
So the thing we want to
talk about is, how can we
manage regulatory risk?
And when I talk about
managing regulatory risk,
many folks operate
in regulated markets.
You might operate in
the health care field,
or in government, or
in financial services,
or education.
Or you might have
privacy considerations,
such as the recently implemented
General Data Protection
Regulation GDPR, which
took effect in May.
So a lot of folks have
regulatory compliance
considerations.
So the question is, how
to mitigate that risk.
Now, your counseling--
your compliance experts
are the folks you
want to look at,
but we also have experience
in cloud at Google,
and we'd like to share
some of our experiences.
So we're going to talk
about four areas today.
We're going to talk about
the importance of conducting
a compliance assessment
within your own organization,
your own vertical.
We're going to talk about the
importance of transparency
about the services we provide,
the importance of contracts
and making sure things are in
writing to demonstrate that
to your regulators, and
then, time permitting,
we're going to talk about some
regulatory frameworks that
have been important-- we've
seen in the last few years
in our work in the cloud.
So let's focus first on
compliance assessments.
So Google operates in
virtually every country.
Not every country, but almost.
And let's think about all
the industry verticals
per country, like health
care, education, government,
manufacturing.
There is potentially millions
of regulatory compliance
combinations worldwide.
At Google we are not the expert
in every single compliance
framework combination
that's possible.
Our customers and their
industry are the experts
in their specific field.
You have your counsel.
You have your compliance
experts, your chief privacy
officers, your
compliance officers,
your security officers.
So you should
leverage what you know
regarding your specific field.
And by the way, your counsel
really can help you there.
What we're saying here
is not legal advice.
You have your own lawyers.
However, we at Google
are experts in the cloud.
And we are also
experts in having
provided cloud services to many
customers who are regulated.
So we have a lot
experience in that regard.
So you can partner with
us-- the work, leverage
that we have in the
industry with regards
to helping people, our
experience, our capabilities.
And the point,
then, is that this
is a shared responsibility.
You have your
compliance obligations.
compliance expertise.
We have expertise in the cloud.
And the idea is
that we provide you
with the transparency
you need to be
able to conduct a meaningful
risk assessment based
on the services we provide.
So when I talk about
meaningful risk assessment,
the key here is to
"think like a regulator."
In all the years that we've
been doing this with regards
to Google Cloud,
there's one thing
that's been a common denominator
across all regulated fields
that we've seen.
And that common denominator
is that regulators expect--
they expect that you conduct
your due diligence before you
adopt a cloud provider.
It doesn't matter if it's
the privacy sector in Europe,
or health care in
the United States,
or financial services in
the Asia-Pacific region.
That's what we've seen.
Regulatory authorities
expect that you
conduct that due diligence.
So look at some of these areas.
They expect you to know the
answers to these questions
before you adopt cloud.
For example, what are
the security capabilities
of the cloud provider?
Obviously, you're going to be
seeing a lot of presentations
this week about our capabilities
from a security perspective.
But you need to be able
to answer these questions.
Who owns the data?
When you upload your
data to Google Cloud,
our position is that any data
you upload into the cloud
remains yours.
It's your data.
But again, regulators expect
you to know that answer.
How is data being used?
Google Cloud's position is that
any data that you provide to us
will only be processed
according to your instructions
to provide the services
and to protect that data.
And the reason why-- how
the data is being used is
so important is because
there are many sectors,
particularly education, or
privacy, or health care,
where data cannot be used for
any other purpose than what is
otherwise required or
prescribed by those regulators.
So educational information can't
be used for any other purpose
than for educational purposes.
Or in HIPAA, for example,
PHI, which we'll talk about.
Health care information can't
be used for any other purpose
than to provide
health care services.
So that's another thing
regulators expect you to ask.
Data incident notification.
We'll talk about that
a little bit later,
but heaven forbid
there's a data incident.
You need to know if it's
going to happen or not,
because you may have your
own compliance obligations
with respect to that.
Regulators want to make
sure you know that as well.
Data deletion.
How do you know that once you've
deleted data from the cloud,
it's actually gone?
Regulators want you to know.
We provide an
obligation ourselves,
a contractual commitment
to purge the day that you
delete it, so you know that.
Data portability.
What happens if you
want to take your data
and move to a
different provider?
Regulators want to know, can
you take the data with you?
And so you want to look
into the capabilities
that we do provide
for data portability.
"What type of data
will be stored?"
The type of data is also very
important with regards to
whether or not it is
regulated by a regulator.
For example, European privacy
law applies to personal data.
Educational records apply to
educational data, of course.
So not all requirements
may apply to all the data
you may be using the Cloud for.
So you want to look
at the type of data
you're processing to determine
what regulations might apply
to it.
Of course, "Where is it stored?"
We've seen regulators
ask customers
to ensure they know what data
centers will be storing data,
or what data centers
may potentially
be storing the data.
And then third-party
audits and certifications.
Is anyone verifying what
we're saying is true?
The one thing I should point
out, and I think a lot of folks
here already know
this, is that there
is a distinction between Google
Cloud services and our consumer
services.
We do not serve ads on
our Google Cloud products.
This is not a consumer offering.
This is not like Google
Search, where you see ads
based on your search results.
There are no ads.
There are special
business-to-business terms,
which I'll talk about.
We have special
administrator tools,
because our customers are
administering the services, not
Google directly.
And of course, we have certain
enterprise services like Vault
for G Suite, which
lets you store
offline copies of the data used
for storage discovery purposes.
So we talked about
compliance assessments--
the things you need to look at.
Now, let's focus
on transparency.
So everything that you
could be hearing this week--
everything that I'm saying
to you could be lies.
How do you know we're
not lying to you?
Regulators expect you to know
that what we're saying to you
is true.
And how do you verify that?
The answer is third-party
audits and certifications.
What that means
is that we invite
third-party, independent
auditors to come
to Google and audit
our data protection
practices, essentially to
verify our affirmations of what
we do are true.
So what does that mean from
an operational perspective?
Let's talk about SOC 2 audits.
So for example, a third-party
auditor will come to Google
and assess each of
our security controls.
So we say that we
do X, we do Y, we
do Z. The auditor comes in
pursuant to a SOC 2 audit.
And they verify each
one of these controls--
dozens and dozens.
I think hundreds of controls.
And the output of that
third-party auditor's
assessment is a highly
confidential, detailed audit
report.
The idea, then, from a
regulatory compliance
perspective as part of your due
diligence is to get this report
and then compare it against your
own regulatory, and security,
and data protection needs.
You compare the two.
You do a Delta
Analysis to determine
if there are any gaps and
then what those gaps are.
So that's for example,
a SOC 2 report.
I'm not going to talk
about everything,
but I want to highlight some.
Now, the SOC 2 report is--
as I mentioned, where
auditors come in
and audit us against a
certain auditing standard.
But SOC 2 is not a
security standard.
And it's not a data
protection standard.
So what we decided to
do a few years later--
we did this starting in 2012--
is that we adopted ISO 27001.
Now, ISO 27001 is an
IT security standard,
where the International
Organization
for Standardization
creates a set of controls.
They write the controls.
And basically, they say that
if an auditor assesses you
and you've achieved
these controls,
then you have attained
this IT security standard.
So the output of that is
essentially a certification.
It's like a diploma,
if you will.
So we have adopted ISO 27001.
But the thing about ISO
27001 is that it's not geared
towards cloud, specifically.
It was drafted originally
a long time ago
before cloud computing
had really taken hold.
So what the International
Organization
for Standardization did is that
they launched specific cloud
security controls, which is
ISO 27017, which we've adopted,
as well as specific cloud
data protection and privacy
controls, which is ISO 27018.
And again, the auditors audit
us against that standard.
And if we attain that
standard, which we have,
then we get a certification.
So as part of your
due diligence,
you look at the SOC 2 report.
We also have a publicly
available SOC 3.
And by the way, the SOC 2
is NDA, but it's accessible.
We have a publicly
available published SOC 3,
and then you look at
the ISO certifications.
Now, the nice thing
about ISO is that it's
an international organization.
There are participants from
virtually every country
in the world.
And they are the ones who
write the standards themselves.
In other words, every
country has an opportunity
to create this global standard.
And the reason why it's
important from a compliance
perspective is that because
it's an international standard,
it makes it more readily
or easily adoptable
by customers across the world.
And it also makes it easier
for regulatory authorities
to recognize the importance
of and the validity
of these standards
and certifications.
You'll also see sector-specific
areas such as PCI DSS, which
we attain for processing
payments for some of our cloud
services.
Privacy Shield,
which is something
related to European law, which
we'll talk about in a minute.
FedRAMP for US
government, MTCS, which
is helpful for
financial services,
particularly banks in Singapore.
So we'll talk more about
various frameworks.
This is why certifications
are so important.
As a matter of fact, I
can think of a story.
There was an
educational institution
in Northern Europe
a few years ago
that were-- they were using
G Suite for education.
And their regulator
sent them a letter
and said, how do you know that
Google is not using the student
data for serving ads?
Now, how do you actually
know as the customer?
So the customer went
through the ISO controls.
They went through the SOC 2.
And they found that there was
a specific control in ISO 27018
that were audited
against, that says
data will not be used for
ads without permission,
without disclosure.
There is a limitation on
how data could be processed.
Remember I mentioned
that earlier?
And they were able to respond to
the regulatory inquiry, citing
the certification that
we have in ISO 27018
and the controls that are
part of that certification.
And you can get the controls
directly from ISO, by the way.
And this is an example
of some of the control
of some of the objectives
and some of the controls
that are reviewed as
part of this audit.
I'm not going to go
through every one.
We don't have enough time.
But some examples-- information
security, purpose and scope
of processing.
Remember I talked about how
regulators want to make sure
that processing is limited?
This is where that
would be covered.
Data minimization,
collection limitations,
not collecting or
using more data than
is otherwise required to provide
the services, communications
security, business continuity,
cryptography, access controls.
A lot of very important,
interesting areas
that you might want
to take a look at.
In addition to-- again, as I
mentioned the due diligence
that regulators
expect you to conduct,
there are also online
resources that are available.
We create white
papers periodically
to help you in your
assessment of our services.
I'm now going to talk
about it in a little while.
But we have recently launched
a GDPR Resource Center
that helps you assess
our services with respect
to the European General
Data Protection Regulation.
We have white papers information
about our data centers,
security and
compliance, encryption.
This is great, because you have
an opportunity to review these.
And then when your
regulator asks,
have you done your
due diligence?
You can say, I've looked
at these white papers.
I've looked at this collateral.
I've looked at the SOC 2 report.
I've looked at the
ISO certification.
I obtained the controls
from ISO and have
reviewed those, compared them
against our requirements.
And there's a lineup
and they match.
Another interesting
aspect is data centers.
Regulators have
often asked, do you
know where the data
is being stored?
Now, some regulatory
frameworks specifically
require you to know
where data is located.
And some of our services,
actually within Google Cloud,
allow you to locate
data in specific areas--
a copy of data in
specific areas.
But they may ask,
for example, why
has Google chosen to put data
centers in particular regions?
So let's talk about
that for a minute.
We choose to place data
centers in certain regions,
as people might imagine,
for bandwidth reasons,
for cost, for energy savings.
But then, of course,
there are policy and rule
of law considerations.
We won't build a data
center in any location
where there is
not a rule of law,
where there is no
stable government.
We want to make sure that
there are protections
against content, copyright,
or trademark concerns
for a provider.
And we can only
build data centers
and will only build data
centers where we are allowed
to do so as a US-based company.
You won't see data centers
in OFAC-restricted countries,
for example.
So we've talked about the
importance of conducting
compliance assessments
for your sector,
with your counsel, your
compliance professionals,
the importance of transparency,
making sure you conduct
your due diligence, and the
information we can provide
to you to help with that.
Now, let's talk about contracts.
Now, third-party
audits are terrific.
They verify what
we're saying is true.
But it doesn't mean anything,
unless it's put in writing.
And we have seen situations
where financial regulators have
asked our customers for copies
of their cloud contracts
with their cloud
provider, to verify
that they reflect
the regulatory needs
of that particular industry.
We've seen financial
services regulators do this
more than once.
So let's have a brief
overview of what we provide
from a contractual
perspective because, again,
these obligations
need to be in writing.
So first, we have the
customer agreement.
This includes commercial
terms, billing and payments,
how much it's going to cost,
what type of technical support
there's going to be.
Who owns the
intellectual property?
As I mentioned, you
own the data that you
upload into Google Cloud.
Those cover the general
commercial terms.
But then, we also
have something--
and I'm going to focus on
this in the next slide,
particularly.
We have something called
data processing terms.
This is a special part
of the contract that
sets forth the data protection
obligations that we have
with respect to the protection
of our Google Cloud customers'
data.
This is something
that we actually
did not have originally.
We had this incorporated
into our earlier contracts.
But having a special
section, a special amendment
for data protection is something
that we implemented in 2012,
based actually on
guidance from data
protection regulators in Europe.
This includes things like
the privacy commitments.
Remember that data
use restriction?
We won't use your data for
ads, or for any other purpose
than per your instruction
or provide the services.
That's where it is.
It's in the data
processing amendment.
A commitment to maintain
third-party audits, right?
We want to keep doing this
and be able to provide you
with these certifications.
An obligation to delete
the data, for example.
I'll go into more detail of
the data processing terms
in the next slide,
as I mentioned.
But also, a cloud
contract isn't necessarily
appropriate for every
country for every vertical.
So for certain verticals,
for certain countries,
for certain areas we have
special industry-specific
terms, special
amendments that would
be appropriate for
that particular region.
For example, financial services.
A regulatory authority
have special requirements
and expect their
banks, their securities
firms to be able
to have terms that
address those requirements.
Business Associates Agreements,
which is important for HIPAA.
That is US-based protection
of patient records.
As I mentioned,
financial services terms.
EU Model Clauses, which
is used to transfer
personal data from Europe
to the rest of the world.
And FedRAMP, which is
for US government data.
So let's talk about the
data processing terms,
which I mentioned earlier.
They are the data protection
obligations that we provide.
And from a regulatory
compliance perspective,
this is something that's
going to be particularly
important when it
comes to working
with regulatory authorities.
It is essentially
the privacy policy
for Google Cloud contracts.
And it was something
that, as I mentioned,
we initially launched in 2012.
But it's been evolving
over the years.
It's not a static document.
We are continually
getting feedback
from regulatory authorities,
particularly in Europe
and in regulated markets
like financial services.
And then we're updating
it over the years
to reflect latest requirements.
As a matter of fact, it was
most recently updated for GDPR.
But we did this in 2017 to be
ready for when GDPR takes--
or took effect in May 2018.
And incidentally, if you
are existing Google Cloud
customers, you want to
make sure that you opt in
and use the latest data
processing terms for GDPR.
Well, let's talk about some
of the areas within GDPR--
or specifically within
the data processing terms.
Excuse me.
This is where we include the
limitation on processing,
as I mentioned before.
We won't use the data
for any other purpose
than to provide the services.
There are no ads.
Data deletion.
This is where we
include the obligation
that when you
delete data, it will
be purged within a
specific period of time.
It's not going to just
sit there forever.
And I would venture that
this is better than what
a lot of people do on on print.
This is where we
include the obligation
to maintain these third-party
audits and certifications.
Because after all,
what's the point
if-- as soon as you sign
up, we no longer do it?
So this is why here we include
an obligation to constantly
and continually do it
throughout the entire term
of your contract.
Subprocessors-- we haven't
talked about this before.
What if Google uses
vendors or third parties?
The regulatory authorities
that you work with
will want to know, is
Google using any vendors?
Are they sharing
data with anyone?
Well, from a Google
perspective, we
do the vast majority of
processing ourselves,
of course, because we're Google.
But we do have some vendors.
And so here we
include an obligation
to make sure that we let you
know who those vendors are.
We provide you
with notice in case
we decide to use a new vendor,
that they comply with certain--
very stringent
security requirements.
And the vendors we
use, even though we
do the vast majority of
processing, generally
would be things like
technical support,
providing 24/7 customer
service, 24-hour access,
different language support.
So they are there.
And this is where
you can find them.
An obligation to
protect your data.
The security measures
that we'll use.
Remember I told you about
data incident notification?
That's something
else that's critical.
I hope it never happens.
But let's say that there
is a data incident that
affects your data.
There's a breach, for example.
Many regulatory
authorities demand
that you have obligations
to your own customers,
to your own users if
there is a breach.
But how can you
fulfill that obligation
if your cloud provider doesn't
tell you if it happens to them?
So we include an obligation.
And we've actually been
doing this for many years,
probably from the first days
of Google Cloud G Suite, where
we provide you with notification
if there's an incident that
affects your data.
And of course,
the other thing is
that we make available a data
privacy officer that folks
can contact, if they have
any questions that affect
European privacy, for example.
So that's why data processing
terms are so important.
So we've talked about
compliance assessments.
We've talked about
transparency, contracts.
And now, let's talk a little
bit about regulatory frameworks.
I want to touch upon finance,
because financial services is
a very big deal.
There's been a huge adoption
by banks of cloud services.
So let's talk a
little bit about what
regulators in the
financial services space
have been asking questions
about in our experience.
So as I mentioned,
all the areas we
discussed regarding
the due diligence
questions at the beginning--
who owns the data?
Where is it stored per
processing limitations?
But then regulators in the
financial services space
also maintain very strict
oversight over their banks.
Obviously, it's a highly,
highly regulated industry.
So regulatory authorities
want to make sure that when
a financial services customer
moves all of their data
into the cloud, that
the regulator still
maintains the ability
to exercise oversight
over that data.
Financial services
regulators expect
that a bank will be able to
subject themselves to an audit
by the regulatory authority
at the regulator's choosing.
And they want to make sure that
if the cloud customer moves
their data to the
cloud, they can do so.
So in our financial
services terms,
we include language that
says we acknowledge you.
Customers, the
bank are regulated
by your regulatory authority.
And that you will, as such,
pursuant to your obligations,
make that data available
to the regulator
if they request
an audit from you,
and that they still
have jurisdiction.
Regulators want to see that type
of language with the customer,
so that customers can
verify to the regulators
that they can still be subjected
to audits, for example.
But it goes beyond that.
Some regulatory authorities in
the financial services space
want to be able to regulate
us, or audit us directly
as the provider.
So we've had to
address that and agree
to these sort of requirements
for certain jurisdictions.
Same thing with customers.
In many different
markets, customers
are expected to be able
to conduct audits directly
over Google.
And we agree to this
in many jurisdictions.
And naturally, we
much prefer the use
of third-party audit reports
and certifications, because it's
much, much more scalable.
But in situations
where that is an issue,
we still agree to
it, because that's
what many financial services
regulators have expected of us.
Another area that we address--
so that's financial services.
Another area that we look at
and we provide services for
would be health care
in the US, for example.
The Health Insurance Portability
and Accountability Act.
You've heard me mention HIPAA.
We do provide
services to entities
that are regulated by HIPAA,
that are covered by HIPAA.
HIPAA involves protection of
protected health information.
And to address
this, for example,
we offer what's called
Business Associates Agreements.
You remember when I was
talking about contracts where
we had three different slides--
where we talked about the main
commercial contract, the data
processing terms, and
sector-specific terms?
The Business
Associates Agreement
would be a great example
of sector-specific terms.
We also have special
implementation guides,
like the HIPAA
Implementation Guide,
where you can review
it and determine
how best to deploy Google
Cloud services when
it comes to protection of data.
This is, again,
white paper resources
that I mentioned earlier.
In providing services to
the educational market,
FERPA, for example, is data that
involves student records that
must be protected.
So we have special
language that addresses
that in the education space.
And then there are other
markets like government.
For example, in the
US, as I mentioned--
you heard me mention FedRAMP
off of the FedRAMP authorization
to operate.
We're at moderate level.
And that means certain
government agencies can store
their data in Google Cloud.
United Kingdom-- the NCSC
and the participation
in the G-Cloud
marketplace to help
government entities
in the United Kingdom
use Google Cloud.
And again, you heard me mention
that ISO certification is
helpful globally in the
vast majority of markets.
In many cases, a lot of these
programs are related to ISO.
And we can expect that
in some governments,
they have special
requirements such as FedRAMP.
Just an example of some of the
financial services companies
that have adopted Google
Cloud over the years.
Again, these are
highly regulated,
yet we have been able to
create an offering which
helps the customers address
their regulatory compliance
needs in the cloud.
So we've been very successful
in being able to do this.
It's a lot of work.
But again, this is a developing
area and very exciting.
Now, I can't talk about
regulatory frameworks
without talking about
European privacy.
So let's talk a
little bit about that.
Now, this involves
the protection
of personal data of
European citizens--
European users.
So let's start at least from
the beginning of my discussion.
This really started,
as far as we're
involved, with the European Data
Protection Directive of 1995.
This implemented very
strict privacy controls
over personal data of Europeans.
And this basically
set the stage for what
Google Cloud and a lot of
our cloud provider peers
would focus on when
creating our services,
particularly when it comes to
business-to-business services.
One very important restriction
of the EU Data Protection
Directive of 1995
was that it limited
the export or the
transfer of personal data
from Europe to any other country
in the world that was not
considered to have adequate
privacy protections as
determined by Europe.
Now, to help address this
data transfer issue--
and you have to remember, when
the Data Protection Directive
was passed, the internet
wasn't really being
used for commerce, right?
There's a huge shift.
So Safe Harbor
was passed in 2000
that would allow the transfer
of personal data to the US.
How many people know now that
Safe Harbor was invalidated?
There we go.
And then in 2012,
because many countries
were concerned that they
couldn't receive personal data,
the European Commission
launched Model Clauses.
And what that is, is these
are special contractual terms,
where if you enter into these
with your cloud provider,
data could be transferred
anywhere in the world,
assuming that both the
customer and the cloud provider
comply with the requirements.
And then later in
2016, the EU and the US
created Privacy Shield,
which is then, again,
another framework that
replaces Safe Harbor to allow
the transfer of personal
data to the United States.
So the net-net of this is
that even though the European
privacy legislation limits the
transfer of personal data from
Europe, there are regulatory
frameworks that Google has
adopted--
Privacy Shield and
Model Clauses--
that allow data to flow through
our global infrastructure
of data centers.
Now, let's turn to what's most
important to a lot of people--
the recently passed
General Data--
or the recently enacted General
Data Protection Regulation,
GDPR, which replaces
the 1995 directive.
The GDPR, of course, is
extremely significant.
It's the most important
piece of legislation
since the 1995 directive.
And the idea is that
it's a regulation.
It's not a directive.
What's the difference?
The directive from
1995 basically
directed member states
in Europe to pass
their own laws that
reflected the requirements
of the directive.
The result was similar laws,
but somewhat of a patchwork,
which made compliance
challenging for providers
and customers alike.
So this is a regulation.
It has direct force
of effective law,
presumably to help
reduce the likelihood
of inconsistent enforcement
or inconsistent laws.
And it strengthens the
rights of individuals.
So what does that mean as
far as what the General Data
Protection Regulation requires?
You'll see a lot of things
here look familiar to what
we've talked about before.
So the core principles
of processing
remain the same as what the
Data Protection Directive had.
Purposeful limitation.
The data will only
be used and processed
based on instructions
from customers
and for a particular purpose.
Commitments on data deletion.
So when data is deleted,
it's actually deleted.
Security commitments,
international data transfers.
You remember you heard me
talk about Privacy Shield
and Model Clauses
is very important
to allow the flow of
data around the world?
Those graded data
transfer mechanisms
are still recognized
and valid under GDPR.
Very important.
There are stricter obligations
for data processors.
I should mention that customers
under the European model
are typically data controllers.
They decide how the
data is processed.
And Google Cloud as the cloud
provider is the data processor.
We follow the instructions
of our customers
only when it comes to
the processing of data.
So there are new, stricter
obligations in GDPR
than there were in the
Data Protection Directive.
And this is based on,
actually, in a lot
of guidance the data
protection regulators have
issued over the years.
That guidance was in turn
incorporated into GDPR.
But we've been doing it for many
years, so it's not new for us.
You remember incident
notification,
where we indicated
that we provide
a commitment to let you know
if there's a data incident?
That's now part of GDPR.
We've been doing it
for many, many years,
but it's now a requirement.
Data return.
There's now a
requirement in GDPR
that there is the data
portability capability which,
as I mentioned to you, we
have as part of our services
and in our contracts.
There is an obligation that
data protection regulators
and customers have
an audit right, which
we've also maintained
for many, many years now.
And brand new aspects.
There are greater fines.
You've probably heard a
lot about GDPR in the news,
because the fines
for non-compliance
can be significant--
very, very high.
Also, GDPR applies directly
to providers like Google.
It's not just the
customer that's
responsible for compliance,
but now under GDPR,
the providers are responsible
for compliance as well.
Records of processing.
You have to maintain information
about yourself, and who
is actually processing the
data, and who's responsible,
and detailed contractual
provisions that
address GDPR requirements.
You remember I mentioned
earlier that we
want to make sure that
if you have already
opted into using
Google Cloud, that you
update your data
processing terms
to reflect GDPR commitments?
This is one of the reasons.
You want to make sure that the
terms you have are compliant.
We have that available online.
You can do a Google Search
and opt in if you need to.
As far as where
customers should start--
of course, you should
familiarize yourself with GDPR.
You should seek
counsel yourself.
We are not your lawyers.
This is not legal advice.
Know the type of data
that you're collecting.
As the customer, you're
a data controller.
So you want to
make sure that you
know what you're collecting,
why you're collecting it
from your employees
or your customers,
the reasons you're
collecting it, making
sure you don't retain it
for longer than you have to.
You want to review your
current controls and any gaps.
You want to make sure that you
leverage the data protection
features of Google Cloud.
You remember I mentioned that--
we talk about our security
controls and our SOC 2
report, the white papers.
What's available
publicly online?
Leverage that for
GDPR compliance.
And of course, GDPR is evolving.
The law has passed, but data
protection authority guidance
continues.
And so you want to make
sure you monitor any updates
to what this may
bring in the future,
as regulators issue
ongoing advice.
And finally, we have
a GDPR Resource Center
that is also very
important when it
comes to ensuring that you have
conducted your due diligence
when adopting Google Cloud.
We talk about contracts
and terms, compliance,
compliance analysis, and
relevant products and services
that you can leverage to help
with your GDPR compliance
effort.
So that's very important.
The other thing I mentioned
was regulatory engagement.
It's important to
stay a step ahead.
So from our perspective
as a cloud provider,
we've worked very closely with
data protection authorities,
financial services
regulators around the world
to ensure that the services
that we are providing--
to help ensure the
services we are providing
are consistent with regulatory
requirements worldwide.
That may involve educating
regulatory authorities
about the cloud, but also,
monitoring whether or not
they are issuing guidance
regarding cloud services
adoption.
And also, being able
to take feedback
from the regulatory
authority folks
and then incorporate that into
our products and services,
like I mentioned at the
beginning of our program.
So let's summarize.
We talked about the importance
of conducting a compliance
assessment in your particular
field and your vertical.
We talked about the questions
regulators expect you to ask.
We talked about transparency,
the importance of making sure
you have the
information you need,
so that you can conduct
a meaningful risk
assessment to address what
regulators want you to do.
Contracts-- the
importance of making
sure you have things in
writing and have this,
so you can demonstrate
to regulators you
have the provisions you need.
And finally, we talked
about regulatory frameworks
and the latest
trends we've seen,
including financial services,
health care, and GDPR.
So ultimately, we'd like
you to partner with us
to meet your data protection
and compliance needs.
And we hope this presentation
has been helpful for you.
Thank you very much, folks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]